là một sinh tộc đã trải qua 1 văn đau thương mất mắt bởi chiến trái nhỉ.
Bên này hết Việt Nam Thấu Hio giá trị sâu sắc của Hà Bình.
Tư tưởng Hà Bình, Hoa Hio, Lòng Yen ai, Đức Ví Tha Tham Dấm trong bản sắc của sinh tộc Việt Nam.
Đà dục túng tội vật qua lối đau, hàn gắn phía thương, gác lại phó cứ,
hướng tới từng lời. Mong muốn là ban là đối tác tiên cây của khắp của ra dân tộc trên phóng thì giới.
Hoa Bình, Hoa Lòng Yen, Hoa Lòng Yen, Bố Lệ Đuều Kẹn Tiên Quết cho hành trình xây dân từng lời ở đây,
công bằng dân chủ và phát triển thị gợp.
Tôn viên giá trị của Hà Bình, dân đổi mạnh mẽ để kiến tạo từng lời bền vướng,
là thống biệt trên thành mà Việt Nam mong muốn hử tất cả đồng cuối tế,
nhân dịp kỳ niệm, thảm mấy năm thành lập dưới lúc quốc.